what's happening you Savages it's
Tuesday October the 10th the checkin is
brought to you by stamps.com listen the
holiday season is upon us the last thing
you want to do is run out of stamps can
you imagine you're sending Grandma
package you got a Rue from a flea market
you know and next thing you know you got
who got nothing with stamps.com your
small business can always be prepared no
matter what the lines look like at the
post office all you need is a computer a
printer and a scale they'll send you
that to take care of all your postal
needs right from home you don't got to
leave you don't got to do nothing you
print your post you print your postage
your schedule package pickups through
the easy to use dashboard and voila I've
been with them for close to 15 12 13
years my wife and I love this stamps.com
is a total Lifesaver for small business
like what we had couple hats a
sweatshirt they'll get you through
sometimes I send socks my underwear but
that's a complete different story
they'll help you save both time and
money with huge carrier discounts up to
84% off ups and USPS who takes care of
you like stamps.com nobody so listen do
me a favor I don't care if you got a
shoe company I don't care if you sell
your blood listen get your business
ready for the holiday Rush get started
with stamp
today right now Tuesday the 10th sign up
with promo code Joey for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and a free digital
scale no learn term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone and at the top of the
page enter code Joey it's that simple
that's stamps.com Cod Joey you're going
to get a four week trial of stamps.com
plus free postage and a free digital
scale so head to
[Music]
www.stamps.com and use code Joey now
let's get the party started welcome to
episode number six of the check-in I
know this is a little bit of a weird way
to start but I got a phone call from
Joey a few minutes before we started
recording the podcast that is the reason
we started the podcast is the phone
calls that I get from Joey just like
this Joey is having a hard time logging
into our recording and this is a few of
my favorite moments I'm going enjoy it
before the episode of the checkin thank
you guys enjoy the episode all right
here Joe hit
record all right I'll send you another
link of the same
link hours I sent it 15 minutes
ago
emails don't
change the email doesn't change because
it's still right it's probably still
like the most recent email you
got what do you mean what am I talking
about I sent an email 15 at at 646 and
72 it's the same
thing I can also just read you the link
if you need me to for you to type it
in type it in for what to Chrome if you
can't if you can't get into your email
if you can get into Chrome or Firefox I
have a link for you that I could just
read to
[Laughter]
you make set up your brows in a few
simple steps
Okay add bookmar your favorite Google
app don't worry about that
skip all
right what the
[__]
pick a
backr what it say pick a backround pick
whatever one you
like I don't know what the options are I
think they're just colors [__] got H by
okay gec shapes perfect the one let's do
earth
go continue all right your Chrome sign
into Chrome don't worry about
it
okay email don't worry about it you
don't have to do any of this we can do
this later if you want I'm telling you
say I'm try to hit next these
[__] are
relent people are [__]
relow into a
trap what kind of trap is Google gonna
set for you I think I put it together I
got do this thing select all images with
cars I gotta play [__]
yeah always great it's the same thing
when I sign up for [__] Sait me with
this
[__] they need to make sure you're not a
robot yeah but then they keep sending me
[__] for like two hours like cars there
there's might coming on that picture
I always get this one
I all right I'm not a
robot okay can you can you type in the
address at like the website at the
top what
website slash okay
s don't [__] it up I
won't so if you after s
is no I it just as you type it in I'll
say
it you know I'm done I understand that
I'll go very slow and speak very loud
all right so it's
s s s is in
Sam all right
six six
seven seven nice two
Jay as in
Jacob
six six seven another seven another
there's another one too all right
six2
j6 all right let's go back
to
and then hit
enter all right entering the studio
there we go boom there you go
[__] turn off your TVs run for
your lives it's over they didn't put you
on this planet just to give up if Uncle
Joey could do it I could rule the world
actually you got to be thinking welcome
back to
[Music]
show
oh what's happening Brother What's
happen oh my God I'm so high I thought
that you were calling me again that
phone call at the beginning is my FV I'm
so happy that we record got that
recorded because that first of all you
handled that a lot better than I thought
you would
like patience my
son like confuses and [__] but after a
while you're like why do I get mad at
this computer I used to get mad at the
computer Jack when I first started it
was living hell and now they try to
trick me again with the doctor's visits
they make you do appointments online and
they want you to check in online and the
other day they made me sign a contract
online I had to [__] drink coffee
till 2: in the morning and trying to
figure that one out what do you mean
like Doc you sign you just click it says
click here yeah sure yeah come on guy
what do you think I don't know
nothing what do you do you get pissed
off at like do you get pissed off at
like parking garages where you have to
pay with your credit card at the machine
when you're
leaving you know yeah I see if you could
pay in the car on the way out and I'd
rather do that because once you're in
the line they can't mess with you I put
20 Puerto Rican cars behind me I
the Indian comes he sees that he ain't
gonna worry about nothing
else oh my God one of the mo angriest
you got do you remember when we filmed
the documentary yes and and so you gave
me banana it was like four in the
morning you gave me banana bread and so
and you got mad because you got lost
driving to
JFK JFK oh my
God I remember ctions and the guy's like
you got to buy a sandwich and I bought
like a bagel that was two days old but
we ate it DG we were [__] up as a can
of worms Oh what about how we we we
pulled You Out of Time Square like those
Hamas of pulling Jews out of the music
festival those poor people I'm gonna say
a prayer for them tonight I've been
praying this [__] because this is
uh it's [__] surreal I don't want to
you know cause a holy war here but all I
know is get ready to rock and roll
little boys we got the call the big Jew
called over to the little Jews and told
them take the money out of the [__]
Banks and the [__] uh what What's the
most important thing
to the Box they put in in the thing I
have no idea what box you talking about
deposit box oh how I thought you talking
about Jew thing most Jews don't know
about say they make believe but they all
got one of them and one of their uncles
name and they got one in Israel taxfree
you know so I know how we don't put it
at the bank though we put it in the
floorboards oh we in the floorboard
under the Yeshiva you
know always hiding something I can't
believe it's good to see you buddy
comedy was light last week I did a
show in Connecticut and I I got high I
haven't gotten high before a show in a
little bit and it was fun I cuz I don't
do crowd work but there was this I like
when like there's a woman like not
heckling but this woman and I were like
going back and
forth and it was just it was a lot of it
was a lot of fun uh like DTF comedy or
something they filmed it they're gonna
put out some clips so you might have
some clips of me now but I was really it
was really fun I got to see I told you
guys last week I got to see Seinfeld on
Saturday and how was
that very interesting
because you know I mean I don't I it's
like levels of comedian subjective but I
would say he's like top 10 most
influential
standups ever I would say I would say
top 10 is pretty
fair and it was just
cool to think about he's 69 years old
with hundreds of millions of
dollars and I have seen seen
other like quote unquote famous
comedians who were older and they kind
of phone it in and it seems like they're
doing jokes that they did in the
80s and he like was not doing that I'm
sure he threw a couple old jokes in
there but and it was it was something
that I think you probably deal with and
I can understand as a comic it would get
frustrating but people were just so
excited
to see him like you could just feel it
in the
audience that like just the fact that
they were in the same room as
him was very exciting for a lot of
people you're a young guy but I know you
know
this Seinfeld went on a tar and I was
there to watch it all as a comic you
know and when the show came on the first
season I was fortunate like you to go
see him into my comedy you know
92 you know I went to see him early with
a friend she invited me that she goes I
know you're a comedian you're up and
coming I got tickets to Seinfeld and it
wasn't a date she was my friend I knew
her boyfriend he was she bought him but
he had a work she and he goes yeah take
Joey he's a comic and I was blown the
[__] away what I saw his jokes were very
Precision I love his Rodney special M uh
the [__] show over the years has been
great he toured with Tom Papa which you
thought he'd be opening which I [__]
love Tom I was hoping he'd be opening
yeah the guy and the guy who opened for
him that was actually something that I I
haven't done in a while because like
that's my the guy did like 15
minutes but I haven't been like
a like an audience member in a while and
something that I don't think I'm doing I
I've been doing doing
well but like I feel like I should do
more of like even if I'm not hosting
like welcoming
people as opposed to just going into
straight jokes he didn't really do this
but like to me it was just like if if
you're there to see
someone like let's like get them in as
like you know like welcoming like
friends Almost well hire DJ khed to Jump
Around in the beginning what are you
bothering me for
listen whenever you have a situation as
a feature actor or an opener you read
the goddamn room
guys you read the goddamn room but I'm
know welcoming if I want to be welcomed
I go to the welcome committee when you
walk into a state you know they you know
the Kentucky welcoming committee you go
in there they got a picture of Jack
Daniels whatever the [__] they do in
Kentucky little runaway Chinese people I
don't know I don't [__] know and you
every audience is different every room
is different I will tell you what I will
give you guys great advice I had
opportunities from
94 to you know etc
etc opening up for big acts you know and
when I got to La for the first two years
I was opening up for like Paul Rodriguez
on the weekends or the the Latin Kings
of Comedy you know and whatever whatever
the [__] I was doing up in Modesto to
keep the lights
on and in those things when you go as an
opener bro if you go out there really
excited you you might die you go up
there jumping up and down you gotta
capture him Lee you're the first guy
going out there unless you got a plan
and you're like welcome to whatever
we're here to see Jerry Seinfeld tonight
and they clap and right there you
[__] jump in their ass all right you
all know Jerry's coming out let me tell
you a little bit about me [__] is Bam
and now you run with him for 15 minutes
you say good night you go in the back
you watch Jerry from the side nobody
knows who you are so they'll let you sit
there and nobody will come up to you and
interrupt you you could W one of the
best things about comedy is doing it is
great but watching it at the level where
you want to
be is [__] you go home and it's like
yeah head blows up yeah every comic will
tell you a story of who they went to see
and knew right from there from what they
felt some of it was funny some of it but
a lot of it is emotional and then the
back of it is the I don't know how to
what word to say I don't know and you
know I'm not a narcissistic we all go
you know what I'm funny in that
[__] when you went to the wall
right I did it when I first went to a an
open mic at The Comedy Works I did it
sitting at home watching you know uh MTV
Comedy
Hour evening at The Improv going you
know what I'm not funny of those three
guys but that first guy that went up
I'll take his ass to the hoop and that
was me just being a car
salesman being a fan of Comedy from this
side and it was just cool for all I
could keep thinking of
about was like Seinfeld at some point
did open
mics at some point and he talked about
it at the beginning that he did the
Chinese restaurant outside of Boston all
the small clubs he
did not that I think I'll even ever be a
tenth of his
popularity but just the fact that he did
literally the exact same gigs that I I'm
doing right now he did at one point
I've always
thought that the coolest thing about
comedy sometimes is where the
Situation's
at when I can't lie to you when I used
to get this newspaper from San Francisco
when I was at your level and I would
[__] read it and study it and it was
uh I forgot the name of it doesn't
matter but it was like a week just for
laps it was a weekly
publication and they would have the
names of
different places you know and what lures
you to those places is like the name
it's so [__] cool you know I forgot
what my point was those Edibles have
been kicking in for the last 20 minutes
uh just that you can do it like you can
imagine yourself there yes you see
yourself there and there just Parts
where I don't know you get psych to play
at more than others but I don't even
know what we're talking about I'm sorry
Doug
[__] whistle fck
suckers I can't whistle fck I should
have left my I should have took my
whistle out of the truck I've been
rocking
[__] you have to charge that
thing what's that do you have to charge
that thing no I don't even know what if
it
ends whistle that's like one of those
Russian whistles you know the ones they
give the Ukraine I don't
know I don't [__] know I love it no it
best thing about you is that you're
always busy in the
weekends I I remember there was a time
in my life
where I was separated and all I wanted
to do was [__] comedy and if I got
comedy on Friday or Saturday it did
something it gave me another week into
life like I was like all right there's
hope and I would eat a bag of dicks you
know but at least there's a little bit
of hope I have a question for you
okay how does it feel like right now at
this level when you don't have work on a
Friday and Saturday kills me I hate it
all right then you're on to the right
[__] game here I feel like a bum I
can't I can't and I'm getting over it
like today I sent a couple emails out
about like just my
availability but I I feel like I'm
bothering people and I I have to get
over that and I I have to get over that
people have been sending me clips that I
have and I don't like any of them and
I'm sure that if I sent them to a Booker
it'd be fine but I I just don't want to
send that out but it it [__] I feel
like I feel like a like I sh I have a
[__] in my pants list I don't have a
weekend gug [__] rub it on your head and
pray for the best but I've done that
before I gotta tell you something right
now at this level or any comic that's
watching this you know like when you
live in like I don't know Atlanta no
Atlanta's got a bunch of Comedy I don't
know maybe a town like you know skty I
don't know what they have up there I'm
just saying skty right you like dream of
going to this [__] club I want you to
do something send them a
package I don't care if they're ready if
you're ready or not I I don't want you
know when you're ready if you hear if
you do an open mic in Chicago and some
guy goes which you'll hear a lot hey man
there's a guy in Seattle it's going to
open up a club and he's looking for
packages send them a [__] thing
you're a feature you get there on a
bicycle I don't give a [__] there was a
time where whatever wherever your gig
was on Friday or Saturday by the time I
got to Thursday I take half the price I
would just call you like what's going on
over there Tom M Joey you were just here
two weeks ago I know but what's the
story I need to work you know you're
looking to work but in reality you're
not even looking for the money you're
looking for the stage time and that's a
great [__] attitude Lee it would kill
you on the weekends like you don't even
know and there's women there's a party
there's a wedding and you're like I
don't want to go because I know if I
commit to that I might do a comedy show
at a coffee shop and that means more to
me than jumping up and down with a bunch
of [__] lunatics at a wedding oh yeah
[__] I'm not getting invited to any but
it just and then I see like you were
saying earlier like I'm funnier than
that person I see people who are very
nice and they're very funny but I see
that they have a show that weekend and I
get
pissed and here's the beauty of it from
the like five year to the eight-year
Mark you start analyzing every move you
do it's a very you have to have a very
addictive
personality when Comics say you know
when people say Comics have listen they
have a lot of issues addiction was my
issue right but part of that addiction
was D if you're not up on I I still
remember delivering Domino Pizza on
Saturday night to punish
myself like I made myself one of those
whenever you have a four hours come in
deliver guy I knew the guy and it
was yeah dog it was great money I would
deliver some coke deliver some pizza you
know Uncle Joey I'm not stupid I ain't
Frido I know you deliver Chinese food
but not I would deliver [__] Peach and
Boulder till 2: a.m. till it got really
crazy like I knew I was going to get
mugged or whatever I would drink coffee
or something I would drink in those days
I was drinking um Mountain Dew with
[__] snooze whatever those things to
stay awake because I was doing triple
runs and [__] no do no do but I still
remember living in Boulder and at one of
the open mics some guy go this is a
Comedy Company he's a magician she's a
feature act they're opening up a a
comedy thing they got like four comedy
clubs and if you send them tapes I
called them I sent them like a [__]
tape not Lee it's
percentages if you get opportunities to
send the tape to Moscow send it because
that's just a number if they call then
that's your choice if you want to go
over there but you know what I'm saying
you know oh I don't know if I like New
Orleans send the tape you never know
where that guy might send
you yep I I you might like your tape and
go you know what I'm not you're not good
for me here but my buddy has a
restaurant in uh New Mexico you do two
shows all you could eat 50 bucks and you
sleep in the back
room and all a sudden you're like you
know what I need some green chili in my
life that's my homework this week is I
have to send out 10 10 emails I can find
10 emails 10 emails on Monday mornings
at 900 am you program them so 9:00 a.m.
they get them they're going to disregard
them but guess
what you're gonna send them the
following week at [__] 9:00 a.m. and
so on and so on and so on and all of a
sudden you're sending 10 emails 12
emails 13 emails the percentages are in
your corner so just keep doing that
Monday 9:00 a.m. when I started comedy
National booking day was
Tuesdays really yeah Tuesday was the day
you bothered the Bookers they
communicate with you from 12: to 4: you
know in that particular City like if you
wanted to work Cleveland do I wasn't
ready but I would just call people and
torture introduce myself how are you
yeah Someday I'm gonna be a [__]
Savage but right now I got eight minutes
with a bad with a bad tooth you know
what I'm saying I love it you know and
I'm so as as jealous as I can get I'm so
happy for one of our good friends I I
spent like an hour with Eric on the
phone this weekend because he got passed
as a door guy at the comedy store oh my
God I spoke to him and I was very happy
and I'm gonna tell you something just to
be honest on the upside I told Eric I
was gonna call
her because she likes him I know she
likes Jen who's I miss him more than you
know what I'm saying like there some
people Jen is
tremendous and I got her number but I
just felt you know what I'm saying she's
she works a lot at the store but it's
better to call her on the sale and I'm
sure I got high I forgot to call
Jen he got this on his
own he got this because I did a show
with him as an
opener
and he she saw him and
him and then told him to keep coming
back this is good for him because Eric
is not only a comedian with a great
future like yourself but he's a
historian he likes
film he likes standup old standup he
knows prior he knows when he told me his
adoration for Paul money I knew he had a
chance because he understood they're
both gay men so he understood let me
tell you my Eric wrote your story okay
you ready okay yeah so I have an agent
right right and then I have a friend
who's been at this agency since 2003 he
was there when I got Spider-Man 2 he was
there when I got
like I don't know but was taxi I don't
know what it was but he was definitely
there for Spider-Man too and many other
things I booked with him he had a boss
named Nancy and I was her client but she
got to be big and she gave me the him
and then I started rocking and rolling
now Nancy wanted me back but I love Dave
yeah F Dave is gay not very
flamboyant but when you see him you know
he's a gay man so my second call when I
got to New York was to Dave that's how
comfortable I felt at the time even
though I was petrified of coid and
everything that came with it because I
always knew Dave had my back so I called
him he's like absolutely I do theater
specifically but if I see something I'll
submit you and we book some great stuff
together I mean we booked some great
stuff together you know it didn't
[__] buy me a car or nothing but it
was you know co-star work on Law and
Order the show with an haway and you
know he's been good
so out of all the [__] people to call
me I see he's calling me from his 818
number in LA because he used to live in
LA now he lives in
Jersey and he goes Joey how are you
hello he's like the strike is back you
know it's over now I can submit you oh
my god blah blah blah blah blah blah
what's been happening we talked about
the book we spoke about by the way it's
got nominated for [__] Grammy
congratulations audio
will it win who gives a [__] we got
nominated 10 years ago was getting
[__] nominated with
felony
anyway so we talked for a few minutes
and he goes Joey can I talk to you about
something I go what's up he goes your
name is on my
roster and a little after the strike he
goes I I didn't even answer the phones
but I kept getting a message from one of
our clients are you ready and I go yeah
he goes it's the gay men's comedy
theater and they love for you to come in
and do a set he goes and I understand
you're a
comedian why do they want you so bad and
I go long story the man's name is Eric
roacher and he goes who is that I go he
says he's a a Hollywood gay guy but he's
a hard hitter my off at a bar that had a
tent in there and you know people would
[__] each other and you have to guess
who it is and he goes oh my god I've
never even gone there and then we spoke
about boy aoy and he's like he was dying
I forgot about boy a Hoy he's like Joey
I would never consider calling boy a Hoy
so he goes yeah they'd like for you to
stop by I'll get some dates for you and
you could swing by but this is the
funniest conversation I've ever had he
was telling me how you
there anyway now you would go ahead go
for it they would go they would love
that's the thing like people might think
like you know you might not like gay
people you might not like Jews all like
my favorite Jews I don't know but like
you know what's my favorite is women
when women like you like I'll never
forget going to the to Denny's on loram
one night after we were you were at the
haha and you would say [__] to like this
waitress I don't even know like it's not
sexual but basic hitting on her but not
hitting on her and anyone else they they
would have called the
cops but there's just something about I
don't know if it's your smile your laugh
or what it is but women [__] love it
they love when you talk [__] to them
crazy man I love them you know I always
yearn for [__] but anyway we'll get back
to that let's take a quick breather here
drop some knowledge on these
people hey this episode is brought to
you by my people over at better help do
you ever feel like you know what's good
for you but you really can't make
yourself actually do it you want a good
night's sleep but you can't quiet your
thoughts you know you should stop eating
take out constantly but can't find the
motivation to cook talking with a
therapist through better help can help
you figure out what's holding your back
so you can find finally move forward
trust me this helps sometimes maybe
you're focusing on one thing and you're
looking at something else you know what
I was with better help for a while and
they helped me put my priorities in
order and what was important and
whatever else was on the back burner so
better help is also totally online it's
convenient flexible and it's suited to
your schedule you can do a therapy by
video call over the phone or even by
message whatever works for you it's nice
and easy maybe you want to see him maybe
you don't maybe you want to wear a
little Hood whatever you want to do just
fill out a brief questionnaire to get
mats with a licensed therapist and get
started on your journey to get your head
together by the holidays so you can eat
lunch with Grandma no problems you know
what I'm saying just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get match with a
licensed therapist and get started on
your journey so do me a favor take care
your brain with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com
Diaz today and get 10% off your first
month if they help me they can help you
that's betterhelp
hp.com
Diaz we're back so don't forget if
you're feeling a little
K before the holidays contact better
help they'll hook you up you'll stop
hearing voices and whatnot trust me if
they can help me they can help you all
right my dog what's going on what else
what you got this week this week on
Saturday I'm at the
jungle in like outside of it's in Boston
it's like a five o'clock show I've done
shows there before it's a really fun
it's a really fun room they sell
crack no
comment they probably do they [__] s
i don't open mic last night where the
host was on
mushrooms that's okay it was it was
[__] really fun he was up there he
was eating a Twix What if he ate what if
he killed 21 people and one day he
decided he about try mushrooms now he
don't kill nobody no more do you ever
think about that if he's happy and he
don't have a gun or a knife who gives a
[__] you go up there and you tell him
listen if the cop calls don't tell him
nothing and then you [__] get on the
mic oh
I love when the if if the cop calls
don't answer that's my favorite thing
that you I love and it's always like why
is the cop going to call
and I love also that the cops call
wouldn't they just come and pick you up
well call means a combination of things
they might call you or they might knock
on the door they knock on the door you
don't open it you just say how can I
help you is this leis I at listen
whatever you got to tell me either talk
to me or put a bottle in the Hudson and
maybe I'll get in the year 202 [__] n
all right d I actually saw something Joe
could you pull up the Instagram video I
saw something cuz I have you seen on
Instagram that like they have phones in
jail
now me yeah what no who of course you
I'm not thinking of going to jail so I
don't think about it in any way of
[__] matter here like look at this
they they have this like they have all
these things this guy's frying Fried
Chicken in prison can you play
that this is in
prison yeah no this is just he's just he
somehow has chicken and he's frying it
like at the stairwell and they have like
they have phones and they have them like
this is just one video that I
found like look at that they just have a
fire underneath the
pan and it just it kills me every time I
like I I spend way too much time on
Instagram but look
at [__] time okay but you know what's
interesting about this man
that you always find a way how do you
how the [__] do these Cubans get on a
raft and decide we're going to America
we're going to make it what belief do
you have you know it's the same type of
belief like it's like listen you
incarcerated us but you can't take away
our
chicken [__] no and there's other ones
like there's one this guy has like
Domino's Pizza
and like
Chick-fil-A you gota remember thousand
situations this could be a halfway house
this could be a three quter halfway
house I mean I don't like I said I
haven't read about that stuff in years
you know I like the legal system so I
would read about all the changes and
legislature and you can't [__] smoke
in there and you know so but I still
remember I was just talking about this
guy with somebody about this guy I met
in the inside when I was young and he
was very
quiet and one day I saw somebody eating
something and I go you make that and he
goes nah the dude in number two over
there and I went in there and this guy
had nachos for Monday Night
Football oh [__] for like
$3 because you were allowed out for 20
minutes a day so on Mondays he would
stock up on he would have to run over
there he was about
56 so he would give me a couple dollars
he I just said listen I don't want your
money just give me free nachos every
Monday and that's how a relationship
started so on Mondays the Chinese
restaurant was closed so I wouldn't get
Chinese food anyway I waste my time in
the bodega because you had 20 minutes to
run to the store and
back in retrospect the distance was
from The Comedy
Store
past the hotel to that [__] bar where
people bounce on the horse and [__]
right right the roadside I don't know
what it is and you had 20 minutes so it
was a three minute run I was
young and I would run into the [__]
Bodega you buy stamps you know a certain
soda you wanted for that night because
they let you out every day you were
allowed to have $40 on you or $20 on you
but then I figured out you couldn't hit
the Chinese restaurant and the
[__]
Bodega so I I used ELO I went on the
phone and called the Chinese restaurant
and said can you have ready by 1207
yeah and I go to the bodega get a soda
ice cream whatever the old man needed
and my Chinese food and that's how we
lived it up and then other guys would
get spare ribs so I would get egg rolls
and soup and you would get spare ribs
and pork fried rice and we'd sit
together at night and eat like gentlemen
in the library or in the HIV
Center I I know that like to me anytime
I think about going to prison it's like
scary but do
you no [__] I don't give a [__] who you
are you know you're gonna walk in I'm
going in there to get raped hello that's
the that goes through your mind if you
don't if you're not real with you know
these people like you know half those
prisons are full of people going I'm
going to beat this and they never think
about
anything I was always very honest with
myself so I started lifting as soon as I
got bailed out I knew what time it was I
I started eating different I started
[__] riding the bike every day back
and forth I hit a punching bag every
night I lifted in my garage
I had a dog which meant I had to walk
that [__] [__] a couple times
a
day what would you say like if if if
there's someone listening today and
they're like [__] I'm going to jail in
90 days what would you have them do pick
a book
list sew your [__] up like put one of
those things times we need a [__] key
and swallow it you know what I'm saying
and now nobody gets it because it's not
coming out and it ain't going in you
follow me but either Bo you got to give
up something if you don't give up the
Muff I'm just teasing anybody dog you
just prepare keep your mind open keep
your loved ones close to you you know
get a support system there's so many
different things that are available to
you go to better help you got a phone
right I contact better help b e t t r h
lp.com Joey there you go should give
better help to people in prison when I
went in there I expected something
different than what occurred but let me
talk to you about something how'd you do
this
weekend Oh I did you know what I did
okay on was the the ba basketball
preseason which by the way I'm so much
more I'm I'm I know I'm wearing a
Patriots hoodie I'm so I'm football when
when you're when like your team isn't
good with football it
sucks but it
I the uh the Cowboys in 49ers [__] me
last night I know you 49ers are too good
I got the I had the under and it was not
good you know man I think that this is
the craziest season I have ever ever
seen in my life and I got i' never you
would never hear me say this in years
but I've heard it so much lately and
yesterday I saw
something that looks so [__]
obvious it was
pathetic and it always something always
happens with either and I love the
Dolphins you know I go to a dolphin
house I I saw the line was at
12 right so I
[__] I go you know what come on
Buffalo's gonna beat Miami's gonna beat
him but you never seen a bookie with a
part-time job they'll beat him by 10:
and everybody [__] goes to bed
you know you went on the cover and
they're happy right there was a part in
the third quarter with two or through a
[__]
interception that
guys it was right to the other guy even
the receiver was like he put it right in
the [__] guy's hand and when the
camera went on him somebody must have
said something he was
laughing I don't know I just felt really
weird I see the
scores and you know you up the morning
with buffalo getting beat up by the
Jaguars but you know what that wasn't
this wasn't my week for that [__] I had
one pick on
Sunday and it was [__] Detroit
giving nine and a half at home nobody
ever talks about Detroit they're like
that team that n everybody's watching
the Dallas Cowboy listen Dallas is
always gonna be Dallas they need a
complete different team complete
different this is the year that the
owner there has to real realize somebody
got to go Jack but
anyway did we take a break yet we took
one do you want to take another yeah we
got to talk about DraftKings that's why
we're talking about football all right
hold on one second guys we're gonna take
another breather here I gotta go to the
bathroom real quick so work with me
DraftKings is coming so hold
on hey Uncle Joey here if you're not
keeping up with the Major League
playoffs you're missing out if you're
not keeping up with the NFL you're
missing out not only are we getting some
amazing games coming up but you know my
peeps DraftKings has an incredible offer
for you to make things even better
listen yeah bet $5 on any game this week
to score 200 instant bonus Bets did you
hear what I said 200 instant bonus bets
and that's not all new customers could
snag a sweeten the deal every game day
this month when you're looking to make
life just a little more exciting look no
further than Draft Kings Tonight last
night you know who I had last night I
had Philadelphia getting the run and a
half in Atlanta you gotta take the run
and a half and if you lose it's like
shooting somebody but getting shot in
the leg you know what I'm saying at
least you took that dude down number two
I like Green Bay getting two and a half
I don't know what happened last night I
think I did too many bangi why anyway it
doesn't really matter when you're
looking to make life just a little bit
more exciting look no further than
DraftKings and I tell you that with all
the confidence in the world it's [__]
fun guys I love their Casino I love
their little DraftKings blackjack right
now they got a special on the football
uh Casino you gotta go on there right
download the draftking Sportsbook app
right now the casino app is number one
online casino app you're sitting there
board the dentist office bam you you go
on Blackjack you my age you're sitting
there in the doctor's office looking at
other guys that are going to die forget
it shake that kadet away and download
the casino app and use code Joey
remember new customers can score 200
instant in bonus bets when you better
Finn on the NFL listen try it for
baseball tell him Uncle Joey sent you
that's Co Joey Joy only at draftking
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL
the crown is yours with DraftKings I
swear to God they treat you like a
[__] doctor anyway you don't even
need to speak Spanish gambling prom call
1800 Gambler or visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net if you're in New
York call
1877 Hope New York or text ho New York
New York
369 we're back anyway
it's can you believe it's
Monday it's can you believe it's Tuesday
the 10th
already no the year's [__] over yeah
it's I dog
I it's so weird how fast this [__]
year
went I'm actually 60 and a half years
old I come on guys I never thought about
this day coming I want to do a thousand
things but I don't want to do any of
them you know what I'm saying every time
I want to do something my smoke reefer
and what I realize I don't want to do I
realize ain't worth doing at this point
I just want to watch you know it's just
a different [__] world and I'm
enjoying this [__] that's [__]
awesome I wanted to ask you because it's
happened to
me it's and some of the funny huh I do
have crabs all right [__] Josh
Wolf and not in a mean way has been
messing with me in hysterical ways at
the hotel like at two separate hotels at
one hotel he got me the handicapped
room and then at the last one in Omaha
he called up and told him that I'm not
violent but I'm severely
autistic and if just to keep
smiling and if I get angry just keep
smiling and they like they were so nice
to me when I every time I check every
time I was down there so I love that
that's in my note now at holiday
in that I'm severely
autistic I was I was Wonder next time
you go tell them that you know [__]
Machin machwitz machwitz is gonna call
over there to take your name off the
list you got better things to do than be
described a little [__] [__] who
can't box you know what I'm
saying where did boxing come into this
what I don't know
he's violent he's nonviolent I don't
[__] know why you bother me with this
questions I don't know did anyone ever
[__] like did you ever [__] with it like
the only time absolutely where do you
think he got the [__] [__] idea
from with the handicap room you go in
the shower the shower's up to your belly
button you gota lay on the floor like
you're 5 foot two and then you don't
want to call the front because you bang
one out and you come on the shower head
and you're like this ain't bad this goes
directly into the sink here then you
Splash your face and nobody knows
nothing I P off my pants what because
the toilet seat was like higher yeah you
got wiggle oh my pee went right between
the toilet seat in the bowl so I was
just I was on mushrooms after Friday
night and I'm taking a
piss and I just feel like my pants
getting
warm and I peed all over them I had to
throw some shorts
away yeah do what I had to throw my
shorts away because I pissed all what am
I going to do I'm not going to travel
with piss on my shorts that's what you
put in your in your bag on top and
underneath you put like the 22 ounces
you smuggle [__] from
Israel I'm gonna need to I got that
little thing in my bag the last time
that TSA looked at
it it's [__] Paran I hate that [__]
different things in your bag when we
travel that wouldn't throw get you
thrown in jail and after times they
never even stopped you
listen what do you mean you put stuff in
my
bag looking back at it the guys that are
successful with a great team and I think
about Gabriel right now B got a great
team Joe Coy's got a great team but I
think of the guys I'm not talking about
management agent publicist all that [__]
that comes with the job when you're at
that
level I think about the people that are
around you you know what were we talking
about about the you said I was talking
about me getting [__] with on the road
but you were saying you bring people
because they're part of a [__]
joke they're part of a running
joke but it's all a joke in love right
and it's the funniest thing that you'll
ever those are the things when you're
selling out
Arenas and you're doing all these things
those are the things you cherish forever
those memories you know I told you I had
a guy in El Paso that was the house MC
but his real business was he cleaned
movie theaters and he cleaned the comedy
club and this guy guys was something out
of this world
because he just was there every [__]
night with a tuxedo on you know he he
had like a little big head he was like 5
foot six he he could have been an
Apocalypto I I don't know what he was he
was married she'd come in but he'd still
hit on
women he had the platform
shoes oh which was hysterical right
and we used to [__] with him the club
owner told me give him a long letter
give him a long
intro like this next guy coming to the
stage went to Catholic
school before high school and while he
was up there reading it he'd be looking
like you know how long is this and the
club owner would go read it and he'd
read the whole [__] thing like two
pages Joey went to prison came out then
he was gonna be a chef but then he
changed his life around he became a
magician and and I would just give him
like a fake buyer I had no credits but I
give a [__] what he says up there they
don't care every time you'd give him
give him a new bio yeah and then he I
worked with him one New Year's and I
realized that he cleaned after New
Year's so I I went to K model one of
those places and I bought that [__] you
throw up in the air you know [__]
confetti that
[__] whatever the [__] they say you
know maybe hi Ray but I don't think you
say that on New Year's what I don't
think you say that on New Year years
when do you say that I don't know when
you I know I've never said
right I think it's yip yip Maru I don't
even know what that means no
no nothing that hip hi hoay is a word
either but yip yip chip chip CH ho
there's a bunch of people
say no one says chip chip jell ho either
but you've been saying that for
years
you said chip chip Cho no you don't have
any Arab friends you say chip
chip I always thought that was British
that's Arab you what I always thought
that was British that's Arab I can't
imagine an Arab Guy saying chip chip
Chell
ho it's Tuesday [__] you guys
need a [__] Tip Top mooo wake up
there you have it what's the word
again you be a Peru yeah yeah the [__]
they
say oh I love it this is the way to do a
[__] Tuesday morning you know what
I'm saying this is it this is the best
way to start I told you [__]
you know a lot of people emailing me and
a listen it is what it is this is the
best of us that we got we're trying to
get into the groove right now now we
figured out you know like when you go to
a movie you eat mushrooms right now our
biggest problem is the time it you know
and I can't I got a kid I can't be
sitting here with a watch acting all
creepy and [__] so you just go with the
full amount [__] it take a chance
Columbus did and here we are this is
what happens at the end of the day
listen I don't need to do dick but I'm
THC fueled you Mark Maguire [__]
drank steroids by the [__] bottle
Uncle Joey needs to smoke his grief for
you know what I'm saying but on this
case I only did a few Bon hits today I
uh ate like five of those [__]
just to keep me honest how to respect we
got the timing right whatever the timing
was
what the timing tonight was right those
Edibles are kicking right now oh my God
I could feel my heart beating and [__]
let me tell you what happened before
tonight this is why I was a little late
gentlemen you know like the checking
Hill a little early prepare
myself I love my
neighbors the pumers are are solid solid
they keep me together when I'm just
about when I'm like what the [__] is
going on with these
people I got a call from her and today I
saw her husband like what's going on I
saw your wife didn't go to work Columbus
Day whatever and he goes yeah I go
what's what are you guys doing for
dinner she goes she's cooking and I go
what she cook and he goes your favorite
chicken scapini whatever with the
potatoes oh now listen I got great
restaurants around here and I've said it
before and I'll say it again she I cook
the [__] out of old them my girl jod
pummer she I'm telling you her chip and
I've had that same dish at two topnotch
restaurants just a
test she shuts them both [__] away
she cook it's like eating sausage and
peppers
with tremendous peppers with chicken
breast oh and then little potatoes that
are
fried and she cuts them just perfect so
you can stick all that [__] in your
mouth all that one shot come on dog are
you [__] kidding me or what and I had
amount of points you know what I'm
saying for today I had I had chicken and
rice I had a chicken breast with black
beans rice and onions that's six points
the last time I check by
well so why were you
late because she invited me over there
like 10 after 6 oh I was already going
into like a [__] trance here so I
just had to run across the street and I
ate and then she goes hurry up you got
15 minutes so I got here at the 10
minute Mark I like to get here a little
early but why are we discussing this who
gives a [__] but I just brought out she
does make really she cooks a lot of good
[__] and she can't because of a job and
I get it when she [__] throws down
she always thinks of me best garlic
bread in the [__] world you know she
makes her own garlic bread oh my God and
she garlics it with butter and then she
puts chunks of garlic in that
[__] and she uses the bread
from leodes the seated bread and she
toast it she's a [__] wizard and then
she makes a garlic dip in case you just
expecting vampires at your house you
drink the [__] thing what are your
farts like after that I used to go over
there and she knows I used to go over
there and dip a whole thing of bread
when I first moved here and she invited
me over and I saw that that was like a
dream for me I love [__] garlic yeah
it's a miracle drug it cleans you out
toxins if you read up on it your hair
blow the [__] away that's why I ain't
got no hair and you're you're doomed
already
but I love garlic I went to that garlic
restaurant in Los Angeles the stinking
time
because it was
phenomenal but I don't have that money
when I was in LA when I went there for
the in 98 somebody else paid like an
agent that wanted to sign me you know I
invited him and my girlfriend and he
[__] you know I walked out of there
with garlic pudding that was not not
those weren't good FS but who's talking
about FS let's talk about week what do
you got planned this week
this week I got that one show on
Saturday where where where details
ticket links it the ticket links is uh
I'll tweet it I'll put it on Instagram
it's the jungle it's the name of it it's
um yeah hold on it's in uh
Somerville the very nice comic Peter Lou
puts it together it's 5 o'clock on
Saturday I'm very excited about that and
then Friday night Friday night I don't
have [__] Thursday night just open mics
this week okay if anybody has a bar up
in the
Boston lead area contact him on
Instagram you know something that you
want to do on an off night sell some
[__] H happy hour menu some [__]
nice drinks get them a mic and give them
50 bucks from the bar and these jamokes
will be happy and you [__] that's the
best way to help the comedy community
they'll be gentlemen they'll act like
[__] civilians you know this is what
it's all about Lee and pretty soon
you're gonna have to get one of these
rooms because it's great work it's great
networking and it's great leverage
people will put you on if you put them
on and now on your ass on a Friday night
at midnight he's got a bowling alley
somewhere in [__] West chat nooga I
don't even you know I don't even know if
that's in Boston I'm just saying
that he's got a [__] room and he's
got a bowling alley and southy you know
what I'm
saying yeah I absolutely need to have a
show but that's there's two people
there's two groups that I I got the
emails for recently that I'm going to
start sending it out that's local to
hear and it's uh that's what I need to
do I I have a cool one coming up in a
couple weeks but we're not talking about
that yet so you got to surprise
everybody no no you just usually yell at
me say I'm not supposed to talk about
future weeks I'm gonna be in wil Bram on
the 18th I see what you're saying I you
TV appearance I thought you were doing
something on the no I don't don't they
pay you
now what' you say what's that thing with
the the women around there and they give
you $ get nak only fans I would do that
in a second if anyone wanted to see me
comedy what I don't know let's not talk
about like like stick to the [__]
Basics you know what I'm saying but I
want to tell everybody I I do got a book
signing October 25th in
Bricktown hopefully Frankie Edo stopped
by my niece is that New Jersey North
they coming down so a lot of people I
went to school with live down there so
I've been getting emils what that's New
Jersey yep very fun 600 pm yeah man
they're listen it's always an
experience I you know I've been trying
to get more but it's like pulling teeth
but who gives a [__] Jack I'm having a
good time I'm gonna see you in a few
weeks oh yeah that's gonna be F help you
I gotta go for a [__] Echo tomorrow
and then Wednesday I meet with the
pulmonologist but I've been going to
Jiu-Jitsu your breathing sound you sound
you didn't I don't think you coughed at
all today yeah I did I got choked up
with the
water okay maybe once but compared to
what it's been it sounded a lot better
it's nice it's good that you're working
on it but I'm happy that you're [__]
sticking with this thing like a soldier
we talk uh you know all the time and
figure out different scenarios we
strategize something that's not in
comedy anymore when you signed with I
was thinking about the the
for people who are whatever thinking
about getting into comedy and what a
manager is and what a manager is and
then you get a manager you're like what
the [__] you know it's it's not like the
old days where every 90 days you're meet
to get coffee and a butter roll and we
talk about your next
move and I don't need to make money on
that this will make my life easier down
the
road you follow me people don't do that
no more little things like that and if
they do meet you for lunch or something
like that it's always when I first got
to La you met with your manager he used
to go to his office once a week check in
what's going on what do we got going on
pretty soon my friends got this my
friends got that but I want to tell you
young Comics something just so you
[__] know this I I've always
forgotten about this this is just to let
you know that one minute you're [__]
hanging out with and then and it don't
mean dick guys it don't change your life
when you see a comic trying to hang out
with an actor trying to pose big time
it's great but at the end of the day you
know what does it sell tickets for you I
rather you get positive exposure learn
now you know while you're young that
young Comics then rely on famous people
to help you you'll get those you save
those for later you save those for later
when you like here [__] I
thought you [__] [__] new
anyway but I had just done The Longest
Yard okay I a dog the the movie had just
been released I'm lying to you it got
released uh May 25th
right this was like the second week
after it was released it had really
caught on blah blah blah blah blah
blah I think the first week I I forget
where it was the war
up but I didn't do
well and now it's the second week and I
know I'm
doing
Chicago on Thursday and
Friday and no on Friday and Saturday and
I'm doing two other clubs one is a
Thursday night when it's a regular club
like under the zany Banner okay the
other one was another club that was
under the
banner I had to get picked up I had to
take a flight to Chicago then take a
connecting flight for two hours and when
I get there yeah they're all there
they're great people but when we go to
this imaginary name El Fuego Comedy Club
it's really a [__] Bowl in alley Le
oh yeah I do those right now I had
sweats on and there was a line of people
like you know in those days there was 48
people that was the line you know what
I'm saying with the world got out I was
dirty and I wasn't Adam sand like
jumping up backwards and [__] it it
ended and I'm like where's the cuz I
flew with sweats
on and you went right on
stage no I'm like is there a green room
they're like
what there's the bathroom or the
car and I [__] just had to change put
jeans on take a [__] Spanish shower
put monkey grease in my hair and here I
am in a [__] bowling now
Lee they bowling during your show
no thank God it was one of the roughest
shows in my life so that just goes to
show you don't it don't matter what you
did on Saturday you might end up in some
[__] town doing a bowling alley on
Thursday and they're touching you it's
like one of those place they all they
all never showered those people they all
have like flannel they chew on straws
and [__]
first captured Outlaw Josie Wales like
those two guys drag him will shoot him
and drag him through the woods they look
like that in that [__] town I
remember leaving there like
pissed I had picked up an agent that was
a big time agent at the time through a
friend and they gave me like a [__]
janor he passed me on to a kid listen to
me the dude gave me five gigs and it's
August
and I goes so what do you have planned
for the the September and he
goes he goes I'm going back to
college something happens after
September he goes I don't know we're
gonna try to get you a different
agent they gave me a kid that they gave
me an intern I was just gonna say
that I never told nobody that but now
you know [__] Tucker and this was after
The Longest Yard it had just been
released 58 [__]
dollars and they give you the intern as
an agent yep God damn it no and that's
listen no shame at least they thought of
me they gave me the intern and [__] oh
i' kill for the intern right now [__]
they could have gave they could have
gave me the share they could have done a
lot of [__] things but just to let
you know guys it never ends I didn't
realize this the drama never [__]
ends whether you're an open micer or
you've been been doing it for 20 years
or 30 years movies TV always remember
that pen that Pen's going to save you
forever something I was never good at
I'm still not good at I try you write a
hundred jokes you get 10 good ones in my
case I gotta write 200 now to get two
and a half are you still writing yeah I
started again and guess what I'm having
a great
time that's
where do you do you go to a coffee shop
again no I don't have the time so you
just sit at home and just yeah last
night I had insomnia and I [__] uh I
couldn't listen I got eight good nights
of sleep I knew a bad one was
coming and about I looked at the clock I
was I laid down like [__]
10:47 and I looked up and it was like
12:30 Lee I was just daydreaming or
whatever the [__] I didn't take Edibles
last night it was the Lord there I
didn't do dick you didn't take any
Edibles I don't believe that you zero
Edibles do I wanted to see the devil
tonight how
disrespect if I came uploaded [__]
from if I start eating them Friday if I
Dro five of them on Friday tonight I
gotta eat 10 of them and they're only
going to give me a shorter high so I
said [__] it take the weekend off no
mushrooms no nothing Jack [__] water
Reaper and that's it I thought there was
no
Reaper what do you mean no reefer you
just said oh no edibles but you're
smoking yeah but I don't
need I just told somebody I was smoking
when we were
together should I tell him about when I
used to tie you up and all that stuff no
anyway I was smoking 38 every two days
Lee remember I would come in with 38s
that [__] Mambo juice with that dress
that dress that tasted like oil you
thought I was poisoning you but I had to
drink it first I would have you pick the
the wrong one all the time I was 100%
you the only person put [__] tow DUS
and then you always picked the wrong one
well there's no right one you probably
put to DUS in both crack label on the
front put it in the front and the with
the [__] uh the one that was clean
and I closed the other one really well
with toad Dutch Jam Malia juice heroin
the whole [__] Chang and i' put it in
the tube next to it and you'd say that
one was broken I'm gonna drink the other
one I'm like
perfect you know I call you in the
morning and you're in the office with
your socks off
yeah I had a [__] you to drink toil
juice dir bastard huh probably got well
huh you probably got your socks off
right now of course I do you have socks
on right now you got what you have socks
on right now of course said I'm not
wearing feet I got the Jew feet out I
got socks and Adidas on how you think I
got here what do you think I was roller
skating
[__] with my big size 13 fungi toe I
got a half a toe dog I'm down like a
half a toe what happened to your toe the
fungus is eating the meat everything
it's all
over no it's it's uh I've tried
everything with this [__] fungi
toenail it's just a it's in my body I
can't use a big Zappa because it'll
affect my kidneys and that's where I'm
at what are you gonna do did you ever
tell them what you call my toe after we
did you Didu that one time no the Ashwi
toe
yeah toe listen you can get his toe in
an arm lock like you grab his toe do a
camural with it [__] you got to see
the size of that ast's toe I do I have a
[__] big ass callus on my on my big
toe I'm telling you look how he climb up
the walls like Spider-Man like Batman
without the Rope remember the old
[__] Batman he had the rope with
Robin behind them and then ask thems
questions bullsh that's my toe what do
and that's my toe that's your
toe what but yeah so you just couldn't
sleep and that's what got you back to
writing because sometimes when you have
insomnia sometimes when you start the
day you just throw that [__] out there
and I throw something out with anger
and uh you know you catch a good thing
in there and you pocket it and uh that's
it I'm really what no go ahead I'm sorry
I'm really down on current
events because when you're a comic you
look at current
events to compete with your life and
bring on
stage and now I'm not into that anymore
it's whatever I read online real quick
if I go I I I look at every Tuesday a
Monday that gets published especially on
my My Little Mac whatever the portable
one I have right it'll say your screen
time and I'm looking at it it's going
less and
less oh really yeah watched it for a
while and I saw the results one day and
God no you know you get high at night
you start watching YouTube videos I'll
[__] get a notebook and put lead
Zeppelin live from [__] mad the
Square Garden I've done it 20 times in
the last [__] 10
years and I'll just sit there you know
I'll go outside smoke come back in
listen to two more songs get upstairs
drink a a Diet Coke Zero with ice nice
I'm like you know this what you do when
you're a stoner what do you want me to
tell
you I play
dra I love draing Casino so I'm at the
lines like if it's football season last
night I was already looking at lines for
the following week I make some notes you
know this is why it's not like you're at
a Bary jumping up and down it's not like
I'm in La when I could go to a haha Cafe
it's not like even if I wanted
it did you put any bets 10:30 I'm
thinking about hitting the crib now
because I want to lurk at 7
AM why do you want to lurk at 7 AM huh
why do you want to lurk what does that
mean lurk means I want to get up 30
minutes before my daughter gets up 20
minutes whatever the [__] it is today I
got up like at
six I come out I pet the cat
I walk out I open up the back door I
make some
coffee I go out on my balcony and I just
sit there and for 20 minutes I don't
know
nothing you know how many you know how
much peace of mind that is and I just
sit there and I stare out into the
Horizon like [__] Rain
Man and next thing you know somebody's
awake I start talking to them I already
had a half a cup of coffee I finished my
mug and now I walk in and it's a [__]
family time till she has to go to
school you know it's not like I talked
to her the whole morning she don't want
to talk to me in the morning she give me
a hug no she'll give me a hug on the way
to breakfast we cross paths sometimes
she eats breakfast before I do the
breakfast is ready but I didn't hear my
wife so sometimes she eats and as I'm
going up I give her a hug in the hallway
but I could tell she's got got to get
ready for school I don't even want to
interrupt her you know what I'm saying
if I go upstairs and break her balls
she's going to forget
something she BR when she goes to school
she got Drums a [__]
backpack you know a Canen like she's
going to Vietnam don't they have water
at this [__] school no they and it's
a problem if they forget it like I I
used I never brought water one day in
school do I got more [__] water cans
te than anything else in this goddamn
house do you bring any around with you
do you have one during the day oh sure
you gotta see me with my little sandal
on walking around looking at trees and
dead deer on the side of the
road I gotta get the [__] out here I got
things to do and people to see all right
Monday night football's about to start
it's Las Vegas giving Green Bay two and
a half with that this morning what are
you picking Lis say I'm picking tonight
I'm probably gonna go with well I did
and I know you're gonna [__] give me
a [__] for I know you gotta go I put a
bet today good that the Chiefs and the
49ers would play in the Super Bowl
that's what I think with the Super Bowl
will be okay that's great that you want
to be the Swami from salami but who you
betting
tonight who Green Bay all right Green
Bay great to see you great to see you bu
week thank you for helping me bring the
computer back to life you're welcome I
was in shock the Edibles were hitting me
I'm about to have a nervous break now I
can't do my favorite [__] show look
at the lighting I look like I'm selling
heroin and playing the organ for a livit
but I love you guys love you Joe thank
you for another fun-filled
episode of
the
check I also want to thank better help
and I also want to thank stamp
but I want to thank you guys for tapping
in with the Savages this week I love you
stay black and we'll be back next
Tuesday Morning Tip Top a goo all right
thanks for
listening
stamps.com listen the holiday season is
upon us the last thing you want to do is
run out of stance can you imagine you're
sending Grandma a package you got a Rue
from a flea market you know and next
thing you you got who gots nothing with
stamps.com your small business can
always be prepared no matter what the
lines look like at the post office all
you need is a computer a printer and a
scale they'll send you that to take care
of all your postal needs right from home
you don't got to leave you don't got to
do nothing you print your post you print
your postage your schedule package
pickups through the easy to use
dashboard and voila I've been with them
for close to 15 12 13 years is my wife
and I love this stamps.com is a total
Lifesaver for small business like what
we had couple hats a sweatshirt they'll
get you through sometimes I send socks
my underwear but that's a complete
different story they'll help you save
both time and money with huge carrier
discounts up to
84% off ups and USPS who takes care of
you like stamps.com nobody so listen do
me a favor I'm I don't care if you got a
shoe company I don't care if you sell
your blood listen get your business
ready for the holiday Rush get started
with snaps.com today right now Tuesday
the 10th sign up with promo code Joey
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
free digital
scale no learn term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com
Click the microphone and at the top of
the page enter code Joey it's that
simple that stamps.com code Joey you're
going to get a four-week trial of
stamps.com plus free postage and a free
digital scale so head to
[Music]
www.stamps.com and use code Joey